soutien d'alain juppé le modem avait
pris ses distances à l'issue de la
primaire de la droite pour laisser
planer le doute d'une candidature de
françois bayrou
du côté de lui dès la désignation de
françois fillon avait aussi entraîné une
division au sein des militants dans les
yvelines les deux formations ont donc
décidé d'officialiser leur rapprochement
ce début d'année autour d'une cérémonie
de voeux commune au niveau local on n'a
vraiment pas le plus souvent une feuille
de papier à cigarette d'épaisseur entre
nos convictions et le point de vue qu'on
a sur les différents projets locaux
départementaux régionaux et communaux
bien sûr ça fait longtemps qu'on se dit
quand même qu'on a toutes ces valeurs
qu'on a en commun il faudrait qu'on les
porte sur le territoire c'est vraiment
pour le territoire pour le fait parce
que la politique voyez bien la politique
au niveau national ça commence à devenir
un peu délétère il ya des affaires qui
sortent les uns les unes derrière les
autres europe et environnement l'heure
est donc à l'union avec des valeurs
communes et pourquoi pas un
rassemblement autour d'un autre candidat
pour la présidentielle
macron séduit c'est dû beaucoup y
compris dans nos grands faut pas non
plus faire de langue de bois pour autant
voilà il ya une méthode à l'évidence qui
est intéressante mais il y a
il ya un contenu que qui est encore
imprécis à l'évidence
donc on va voir ce qu'ils proposent ça
interpelle c'est intéressant
les jeunes me suivent il a amené un vent
nouveau de l'air frais donc on peut pas
faire comme s'il n'existait pas c'est
pas possible et pourquoi pas des
candidatures communes aux législatives
une question que doivent évidemment se
poser les responsables des mouvements
lors des européennes de 2014 les listes
udi modem avait totalisé 14 % dans les
yvelines
derrière l'ump et le fn mais devant le
parti socialiste